oh there just happens to be a camera
here with a mic on this is Mike who mics
so on so there's this sketch on Saturday
and I live starting that [ __ ] chick
Dakota Johnson Don Johnson Don Johnson's
daughter from Fifty Shades of Grey
apparently this get pissed off a lot of
people know why so much Don Johnson so
Don Johnson I mean Dakota Johnson image
of Don Johnson was a dog please would
have been a very intimidating Christian
so the sketch pissed off people and I
want to see you a pissed-off people so
much
well this is it you need end up with
your bag no that's all right I got it
listen walking around mother dad it's
okay just make sure - how are you gonna
get there you know you can stay home do
another year of high school
very funny well I'll see you
Thanksgiving
dad yeah
Thanks
looks like you're writing
Oh dad it's just
take
Wow
Isis will take it from here dad
oh I I don't I don't know I think was
that bad well funny I don't think it was
bad though like well I mean is a pretty
scary thing of course and it's going on
yeah to this day which has now changed
entirely sure what I feel like they were
trying to say something like satirical
but I don't quite know what it was I
thought it was just a funny sketch about
how this girl's going off to college but
it's really Isis that's funny I thought
it was really funny when they were just
doing like a normal commercial like that
was funny too because that was cracking
me up I mean that was funny because it
was like it's building up so hard for
some kind of reversal so it becomes
funny just how much yeah raw emotion
they're trying to pack onto the
gentleman I get the humor if it was like
a cartoon it wouldn't have pissed people
off as much I'm still trying to figure
out exactly what they're doing with this
sketch but it almost feels like it would
be more poignant at least if you feel
it's kind of weird it's just like
they're they're like a white father and
daughter like it would make more sense
if they were actually where Isis is but
that's what I think makes it funny but
are they like recruiting American
teenagers like is that like in real life
yeah it's like is this related to a real
situation and thus is it satirical or is
it just weirdly absurd like depending on
how I respond to this will determine the
point of view other people have towards
me if so that if that's happening in
real life that is horrible because Isis
is like known for being very savvy with
like bringing young people and so I just
didn't know if they were if there was
like some kind of thing about them
recruiting in America or something like
that
hmm I mean that's still like a pretty
heavy situation to make a joke about
let's find out Isis recruits a teenager
yeah three Denver teens
okay so CNN says that yeah that's a have
may keep me nervously laughs oh I point
out my emotions that's what I do I just
don't know how to feel maybe I'm missing
some biting piece of satire or maybe
it's because it's real people like your
family guy did it people when I'm gone
pissed off that's probably got something
to do with it still I mean just just
poking the topic and all is like whoa be
careful yeah yeah you know like I've
said a lot of offensive things on the
show and every once in a while I'm like
what's pretty mean like every few months
I feel yeah but usually it's like haha
it makes me laugh at you're upsetting me
well because you know you in and of
yourself for sort of a satirical
character the [ __ ] is that noise it's
all the people you've offended Ryan
right as he exists in this time and
space is a vaguely satirical person
because the things he says that are
ignorant are done knowing of their
ignorance so the people what I do are
like audience surveys I do social
experiment like you playing a guy who
has these beliefs that you find not to
be true I got it I got to tell you guys
what happened trust me Jerry it is worth
the interruption along and it totally
relates all right so there's this guy
some dick you get a lot of hateful
comments like hateful comments come in
every once in a while and after a while
they just become kind of funny and you
just ignore them yeah but every once in
a while every once in a blue moon there
comes a comment where you are debating
taking the high road or the low road oh
and this one I'm proud to say I took the
low road I want you guys to read all
these comments oh he must have deleted
it [ __ ] no it's right here it's the top
132 replies
love it so this guy said something
really mean about my girlfriend in one
of our videos together wow that's really
mean go to the brutality and story
trailer Mortal Kombat X reactions really
horrible and he is one of the top
comments and you will see like that yeah
so many people there's a lot of replies
to it so I don't want to resit I want to
say it out loud this is that mean to me
right
so it's mean in a way that's like it's
really attacking it's like super
insulting to me I'm like that's my girl
oh yeah that's like so much of what's
wrong with the comment board era is like
few people would actually say that in
person but a lot of people would say it
online they say the most now these
things and I thought was really that's a
person so I went on Facebook and Twitter
and I was like hmm if I just reply back
to this guy we'll just go on a
back-and-forth war yeah how do I get
this guy to really shut the [ __ ] up I
screenshot into the comment yeah told
them what video was on and I said who
wants to tell this guy to go [ __ ]
himself
Wow that's okay he's looking doing
social media event some people were not
happy about it and on it yeah like I
know wasn't the best thing to do but you
can say something that mean yeah like
you can handle it if people are gonna
tell you go [ __ ] yourself
yeah there's about 32 replies on here
and you should check it out if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects and Jerry has a channel
two reasons to Jerry where you could
check him out while he does movie
reviews in the car oh and we have an
Instagram and Twitter social media plug
and Internet get connected